well here we go after a dominating game
one win by Vegas golden knights they're
at it again tonight facing off the
Florida Panthers yeah a big sense of
community Pride all over Southern Nevada
whether it's us whether it's the
businesses the team's success is where
we're all looking eaters now reporter
Joshua pagera is inside T-Mobile Arena
ahead of game two Joshua you're talking
about something folks can do to show
their pride
yes good morning Sherry Nate I have
exactly what people can do and it's
permanent if they want to show off the
pride but right now look at the Teemo
Marina pretty empty but not for
tonight's sellout crowd of 17 500 people
here to watch tonight's as a nice look
to secure their first championship and
it's so impressive you think about it
the team has only been around for six
years since the franchise will form and
now the whole city is rallying around
supporting them as they look to secure
the Stanley Cup one example of that is
Revolt tattoo the tattoo parlor has
several artists outside T-Mobile Arena
on game days doing free tattoos of the
golden knights logo this has happened at
every home game since the knights made
the playoffs the lines have grown during
game five in the Western Conference
playoff 100 people were in line waiting
for a tattoo
get to about 35 to 40 per game because
of just clean in between breaking down
and cleaning up stuff so but that line
has been 100 deep sometimes expecting it
all to get tattooed but you know we're
getting to as many as many as we can
now your options are one of three logos
one color and the tattoo is about two
inches big now Revolt has tattooed
already some of the executives and
players here Sherry Nate I want to know
are any YouTube getting a free tattoo oh
wow well